[Music]
[Applause]
luno
the fastest easiest way to buy crypto if
you're just getting into bitcoin
it's the perfect place to start
guys anna welcome back to the layout
heil pen show
powered by icon plus so as always some
quick news for you so bloomberg has said
south korea
is the world's leading innovative
economy with icon positioning itself as
the gateway for financial institutions
deep by web3 and did solutions
now this show is sponsored by block five
so a quick shout out to them
um i use them to add up to 8.6 interest
on my usdc
and you can actually get up to 250
dollars
um when you sign up with them so i've
left the link for you in the description
and in the comments
and before we bring on my guests a quick
shout out to
coinflip so you can actually get 10 off
your transactions with them
um with a discount code i will leave
that rolling somewhere in the bottom
now before i bring on my really
brilliant guest today um who i'm sure
you guys probably know
who they are already if you are watching
on youtube please don't forget to hit
the like button
hit subscribe so you never miss any of
these amazing guests
now joining me today are the names
behind the social network the bitcoin
billionaires and of course
the guys behind the crypto exchange
gemini it is of course
tyler and cameron how are you doing guys
hey doing great thanks for having us
yeah absolutely pleasure nice to see you
cameron nice to see you too
all right so guys firstly thank you so
much for coming on um i'm super excited
to
jump straight in because there's been
some huge news this week
um you guys are partnering with um ben
mesrick again
which is really exciting but this time
you guys are executive producers um
of the anti-social network so talk to us
how did this come about what is it about
tyler jonah go for it first
sure we we first met ben about a decade
ago when he wrote the accidental
billionaires
which became the movie the social
network and then we reconnected
a couple years ago uh because he wanted
to write a book about bitcoin
which became bitcoin billionaires which
were portrayed in
our early journey in in bitcoin and then
recently with the wall street bets game
stock drama of last week
he wrote a treatment that uh
mgm picked up this weekend
and we're going to executive produce so
that's our history with ben
so what's this gonna look like cameron
we'll come to you what's this gonna look
like right so for those that don't
really know what happened with gamestop
explain anti-social network because
that's a bit of a spin-off from the
social
network yeah so it's an interesting
story basically
um a bunch of people on the wall street
bets subreddit
um started buying gamestop which was a
very heavily
shorted um stock i think over
like 150 more than the actual amount of
shares or
float um so a few hedge funds uh we're
trying to drive this company into the
ground
and a bunch of these individual traders
which refer to themselves as d
gens and um another other things other
terms or whatever
um basically banded together and uh
ran over this hedge fund and i think the
hedge fund lost something like four or
five billion dollars
and it was sort of this triumphant
moment where individuals sort of
um stuck it to um the institutions
and almost always historically it's been
sort of the other way around
and it was a really interesting moment
um
and that's kind of how it all got
started i think the wall street bats
forum
in reddit has grown by something like
six million
users and a lot of these individuals who
trade and
and go to gamestop and believe in the
company um
but also kind of um believe that the
system in wall street is broken
and and rigged against them so a lot of
this is is really
sort of almost out of protest um uh
against
the system um and things like that so
that's sort of the
the general uh gist of what's been going
on
but the whole against the system so i
have a quite an interesting
interesting way of looking at this do
you think this is something which is
predominantly kind of
an idea within this online crypto
community because i know i saw you guys
on cnbc
and you were sort of putting forward
this idea and i think particularly for
tyler it didn't go down so well
yeah well um last week the
robin hood app halted mysteriously
halted
the buying of certain tickers of
gamestop
and amc but um allowed you to continue
to short them
and so people sort of saw that
centralized power saying sort of be
platforming you and saying
hey you can't trade these now you can
only sell them you can't buy them so
that's where a lot of the outrage was
that the
little guy um was being told like hey
now you you can't trade this
and i think it got a lot of people
thinking about um
uh crypto bitcoin and defy because
there is no de-platforming in bitcoin
there's no de-platforming
in crypto there's no call to make and
whether it's
a clearing house calling or a hedge fund
calling a clearing house
um there's no one there you can't make a
call to
the clearinghouse is the blockchain uh
crypto settles
uh atomistically in in real time
and you can't call the blockchain and
say hey
um risk concerns increase margin um
stop that going through and so the
decentralized nature of
bitcoin and crypto that power really
came
to center stage at the same time
that um how so few hands control
centralized finance and a few people
can tell um you know robin hood
or all their users now you can't
actually
trade this and so that's where a lot of
the outrage
and confusion but also the light would
shine onto
the the centralized system and how few
people
actually run it and the establishment
makes uh the decisions for you
so that was really the big eye-opener
for
for me and a lot of people um the whole
world frankly last year
last week except for the guys on cnbc
though
yeah no they they were they were shocked
and dumbfounded that i might suggest
that
um someone may have leaned on on
robinhood
to shut down trading on one side
which we know actually now has been the
case
the clearing organizations did lean on
robin hood
and it's unclear um who leaned on the
clearing organizations and
the other element that makes this
particularly sort of nefarious feeling
and
maybe there's a good innocent answer but
we haven't heard it is that
i kind of understand if if you say hey
we gotta shut down
trading on both sides so you can't you
can't buy but you also can't sell
yes um and then if there's uh a margin
issue or a reserves issue
then you shut down margining so you
allow people to
uh buy and sell without margin so a you
could just shut it all down
right so it's not just the buying and
selling you shut both you freeze the
entire stock
or if you're not going to do that you
freeze margin but you allow
people to trade with full reserves so if
they actually have the cash on hand
then they can make the buy as opposed to
borrowing so
the idea that the it's the
clearinghouse's fault
doesn't explain to me why you shut down
one side of the trade and not the other
um and uh and why
you wouldn't shut down just margin but
allow fully funded full
reserve trades to go and so that's
definitely
that adds to the nefarious feeling
around it
the feeling that the goal post was
changed
that the the playing field's not level
and once
the retail investor starts to win the
uphill battle
they just tilt the playing field
you know even more to make it steeper
and harder so all of those whether
they're optics or whatever
maybe they just have terrible pr um and
they don't know how to manage this
crisis but they've been through a lot of
crises before
not quite this level but there's been a
lot of stuff in the press
about you know the commission free
trading which really isn't
free um the gamification
of these platforms it encourages people
to
um trade and invest in ways that they
maybe don't fully understand
um so they've dealt with like some
headwinds and pressed before
but like the fact that we still don't
really know
and people have been digging for answers
and it's almost
a week later um that's hard to
understand
yeah and it seems like the the questions
aren't being asked a ton
i mean i think uh elon interviewed uh
the founder on clubhouse but i i'm not
seeing
sort of uh and maybe i'm just not seeing
it in my feed or wherever
of journalists like running up the chain
okay robin hood if it wasn't you
then it was a clearinghouse who in the
clearing house and and let's get some
answers here right
it's a very opaque um system with like
endless
plausible deniability and it all really
underscores
the the the sort of the importance of
defy um
the permissionless nature and that's
really where it's all going i mean
gamestop was this this battle on the
turf of wall street in the system
robin hood's just an extension of that
system
it's a horse with a better saddle it's
got fancier marketing at the end of the
day
it's beholden to the system we saw
firsthand
it's like playing um a football game and
uh american football and and
um you know one team's not allowed to
score
for a quarter hey you can only play
defense you can liquidate your position
but you cannot
offensively score um and go play that
game
and defy doesn't have that movable goal
post and and that's where it's gonna go
it's
it's sort of it's less about hey let's
go
fix this system that's that's not
transparent and you see
it with money too right the the the fed
in the u.s it's a it's a board i think
of 12
governors making decisions behind
a door in a closed room we have no idea
and then they come out and say hey aha
we we've done
this it's like the wizard of oz and and
people are
are waking up and so gamestop was it
wasn't just about a ticker
or a price um it was really this
awakening
of like wait a second this is just the
system
and what is what alternatives do we have
and that's how we get to and that's why
we've been excited about bitcoin and
ethereum for
um the better part of eight years and
you know we're just seeing more and more
reasons um
for for them and the need yeah i mean i
think
i for one hope that this is um
you know one of those things that will
wake people up to cryptocurrency i think
the whole corona virus the whole
printing of money is sort of one thing
that's been able to wake people up a
little bit
um i hope this is another thing
especially um for you know
gen z but in terms of the movie that's
coming out
can you give us an idea of how it's
gonna look i know it's still super early
days but what kind of angle are you
taking and also in terms of key players
how are you going to do this because
there aren't any you know actual faces
behind the reddit group it's not like
you know
social network where you had yourself
you had mark zuckerberg you had eduardo
these were all personalities
um how are you gonna do this yeah that's
a really
great question and and ben um mesrick is
is super talented maybe one of the best
people in the world of sort of
teasing and pulling the story out when
we met with him a couple years
ago about bitcoin he had read in the in
the new york times that we were
had become bitcoin billionaires he's
like wait a second okay i need to reach
out to these guys and talk to them and
see what they're up to
and we sat around for like an hour or
two and kind of told them what we had
been up to
and he's like i think there's a story
here and we're like
are you sure i don't know it seems like
pretty normal like
you know day-to-day for us um and then
he kind of came back and was like hey i
think this is like actually really
really interesting and these are the
different things i want to talk about
and he's a masterful storyteller in that
regard
and so he's actually already talking to
the mods on the wall street bets
boards he's talking to people in hedge
funds and finance
and and he's sort of very good at
getting to sources and
and teasing out and pulling out the
story and then building a cohesive
uh sort of three act um
uh narrative that that's really um
built purpose-built sort of for for the
movie so
um there's gonna be people like roaring
uh the roaring kitty
um youtuber um who's hilarious
and actually has been talking about
gamestop for like well over a year
he's like sort of built for for movie
and and this kind of medium and there's
other characters like that along the way
so i think it's going to be incredibly
colorful
and it's going to be sort of uh uh you
know the
the internet like it's going to capture
the zeitgeist of
of this movement and the internet and
all these different
individual sort of this this bee hive
like
um coming together um so i
i i think it's gonna be really
interesting yeah i saw
ben tweeted he was like i'm gonna put
all of your tweets in the movie
it's gonna be really just sort of
showcasing um you know
what all of this is really um yeah go
for it the beauty part about this is
that so much unfolded out in the open
the wall street bets channel right
anyone can see that
the twitter the area that people can't
see is
the decision-making of robin hood the
calls
or the inquiries into the clearinghouse
or from the clearinghouse to robin hood
the decision-making of melvin capital
what happened in melbourne capital what
happened
at citadel that side is completely
private um and obfuscated from the
public but the wall street bets
and the twitter and roaring kitty um
all that's out there you know so so that
that's
that that part's easy to sort of bring
to the silver screen
right yeah i think it's going to be
really interesting to see how this
happens and if you know you guys and ben
are able to sort of
really put forward the lack of
transparency there
i think it will play an amazing case um
there's there's such a uh crazy
intersection i mean elon musk is a big
part of the story right
yes i'm so excited sent it uh to the
moon
and so there's sort of that that
parallel uh
intersection with elon like why is elon
involved in the game style
or why is he talking about it um and i
think you know mark cuban has talked
about it we talked about it
um there's there's so many more done
what's up i think he just put 700
million into amc i just saw by the way
before we went live
700 million who put that in i think or
maybe i'm i think
i lost 700 000 because
uh the stock was was halted so he bought
at the top and sold at the bottom
so he's upset that he lost money because
robin hood and vlad decide vlad the
stock impaler decided that
hey you can't you can no longer um
yeah vlad the stock impeller i think
that was elon musk
named for him when he interviewed him um
but it's fitting but yeah because
you know um vlad woke up or someone woke
up and said you can no longer buy this
dave lost almost a million dollars
yeah i think it's terrible yeah um and
and the thing is um you know the social
network when it came out in 2010
um is really the first
movie about sort of modern um the modern
college experience the modern tech
experience entrepreneurship startups
uh when we were at harvard um
i think computer science might have been
like the least popular major
um because it was in you know the
dot-com bubble it happened
in the late 90s early 2000s people are
still
sort of reeling from that and i think
you know this story sort of has the
opportunity to be sort of the first
modern story about like the internet and
the subcultures and the subreddits and
all
all those um different uh you know
elements
out there and and capturing the time and
it's
it's about 10 years later and it's sort
of like the timing lines up every 10
years there's this like new
zeitgeist and i think it has the
potential of capturing
uh so much that's going on right now
with
like the issues of centralization and
decentralization
the movements of bitcoin and things like
that so it's going to be um
incredibly colorful maybe more so than
the social network
oh i think so i think it's going to be
far more colorful as you put it but i
want to talk about the social network so
i do want to go back a bit to
how we all first heard of the wink of os
twins it was obviously because of the
movie it was because of facebook
so you guys are kind of seen initially
um
as the bad guys because you guys were
the jocks and mark was
you know the nerd so we sort of felt
sorry for him but after time that
narrative obviously began to change
so i do want to hear about that moment
um
that iconic moment when you found out
that mark had potentially
stolen your idea yeah look it was
it was a very convenient narrative to
pittus as sort of the the jocks the
establishment
um the bad guys um the guys in karate
kid who were cobra kai
um i just started watching that on
netflix and it's pretty
pretty awesome um show highly recommend
it
um but yeah like it was a convenient
like 80s narrative
sort of fast forward we kind of now see
facebook as the establishment
i think um history or time has a way of
sort of the truth surfacing
um and and i think a lot of folks were
like wait a second you guys can't be
like
jocks and and idea guys and executors
and tech guys that's not for you that's
for the fuzzy nerd
people over here and it's like wait a
second no
that's just not the way the world
necessarily has to work um
and when we first read about the
facebook we read about it in harvard
crimson
in february of like 2004
and we're like this sounds like our site
this sounds like are there more than one
mark zuckerberg at the school because it
is a twin
like what what it was an incredibly
uh surreal experience and
kind of um blindsided us and really was
just a huge punch like in the gut we
were just like
what what just went on and then we just
basically had to figure out what the
right path forward was
um we went to the
the university president uh larry
summers at the time
uh there's a scene that's pretty pretty
hilarious in the social network
uh he's got his uh shoes up on the on
the on the table
he's incredibly uh dismissive scornful
all of that's true um spot on
none of that in fact uh if anything they
they downplayed it
um he's incredibly unhelpful
um and we were sort of uh confused
because
the university has like an ethics uh
code and a rule of conduct and we're
like well
gee okay you guys don't really care
about any of this stuff interesting
okay we were sort of uh mistaken on that
but he did say hey
go to the courts that was his advice and
and we did and you did
that was really our only um uh uh course
of action
there and uh you know it took uh
many years um but we got to a place you
know and then moved on and and really
the last
10 years have been all about crypto i
mean look uh
facebook is obviously grown a lot it's
it's a
it's it's has its um issues or you know
there's a lot going on but we're really
focused on on bitcoin ether um
and cryptocurrency in general and we
started gemini um
our exchange gemini.com um
in in 2014 it was sort of an idea in
we launched in 2015 once we got our
trust company license
and we're just basically trying to
create a platform where it's super easy
for you to buy sell and store and now
lend
your crypto to earn yield um and make
like a platform that's super simple
because i think a lot of people like
once they sort of buy into bitcoin or
ethereum they're like i get it
i understand the story but how do i get
it and do it in a safe way
when we first got in in 2012 uh
we there wasn't a safe way we took on a
ton of risk had to build our own
cold storage system which is chronicled
in the bitcoin billionaire's book
it's a really fun uh chapter i think
people tend that really resonates with
people they they often like
cite that um that uh that chapter
and we basically built gemini to kind of
help solve that
problem and mainstream this movement
yeah i want to focus on gemini but
before we do because
bitcoin came first i want to do it i
want to do it we're going to do it and
we're going to talk about the
the new earn feature but before gemini
you guys bought bitcoin in
ibiza so i do just kind of want to talk
about that because it's totally random
and actually it's really important
because what what's really unique with
you guys is that you're at the center of
two of the biggest
um revolutions that we've had in the
last decade right so
you had facebook which kind of sparked
social media and then
now bitcoin which has been a huge
revolution so how did you stumble across
bitcoin yeah so we found love in a
hopeless place um
literally we were we were in ibiza um
in the summer of 2012 on vacation we're
not looking for the next big thing
somebody from brooklyn actually
recognized us from the social network
the movie and said hey
you know started talking we started
chatting and he said have you guys
thought about virtual currency or
bitcoin and we hadn't at the time like
tell me more um so we started chatting
about it
and at first it sounded um a little
crazy
and then we took a shot of tequila and
it started to make a lot more sense
and uh we we connected uh stateside
and um started reading up on on bitcoin
and we're really blown away by what we
saw as like a money network a monetary
network
um and money really is the ultimate
social network when you think of it when
you think of
why gold has value it's because people
are willing to
accept it and they believe in it they
have faith in in
in that um instrument and and bitcoin
uh really has a lot of the similar
properties and we sort of said
wow this feels like it could be the next
big thing it's either complete
or or you know very binary or could be
incredibly
enormous a incredible uh
network and invention and and just the
the the risk of sort of not being a part
of it that fear
was was huge we have to kind of figure
this thing out and we started talking to
bitcoiners
and getting really um
they were so passionate like the energy
and
it felt like there's this little secret
hiding in plain sight that we had
stumbled upon
and and we couldn't like get enough of
it
so we we did the uh the the crazy thing
of uh jumping in uh you know
just into the deep end and buying a lot
you know buying a ton
and i'm not sure we even at the time
could totally articulate it because
bitcoin's kind of a complex thing
but we felt it we knew we knew like this
this is going to be
um incredible and in that buying process
we started to think about okay well how
do we kind of help
build this industry as opposed to also
you know investing is one thing but you
also want to be
we're builders at heart we love building
things and so what can we build what
should we build what do we need to build
to make this thing um really go
mainstream
yeah and obviously you went and you
built gemini so i do want to talk about
gemini a bit because
um you guys are you know you just you do
everything properly obviously and
you know you've got the regulation in
place and i think you never listed
xrp is that right because of the the
lack of clarity
that's correct yeah so so with that in
mind
um you know you're obviously very much
in line with everything so
what are your thoughts on regulation and
sort of mass adoption and this
space moving forward do you think
regulation is going to be really
necessary and how
is gemini going to sort of work with
these new developing regulations and
laws
yeah so our belief is that thoughtful
regulation
builds really healthy vibrant strong
markets
it's also the only way to um
build a bridge between um your money and
your bank now
and getting into crypto so gemini was
not
a regulated new york trust company with
money transmission licenses
in almost 50 states um if we didn't have
an e-money license
in the uk if we didn't have a license in
singapore
uh pending then it would be very
difficult for you to go to your bank
and wire money or convert it into
bitcoin
ether crypto um because we have
those licenses because we've worked with
regulators to become
regulated and help them shape and
educate
them on the regulation to build the
right regulation
you can open an account with gemini you
can wire
your money to our account and you can
buy uh bitcoin ether
you can keep it with us you can store it
but you can also withdraw it
um right into your wallet into
another exchange let's say coinbase into
a d5 protocol like ave
um and so that is the only way we know
how to
sort of link up these two worlds and
build that adapter bridge
portal so that people can come over um
people should be aware also um while
we're on the topic of robin hood
um and dogging on them a little bit is
that when you buy crypto there
it's actually stuck in jail it's a
walled garden
so if you buy bitcoin at robinhood
um it's actually stuck there and you
have to sell it into cash
wire the cash out and then wire the cash
back to
gemini by bitcoin the problem with that
other than the friction
in the inconvenience is that when you
sell your bitcoin exposure
in robinhood it's a taxable event so
um it's very efficient inefficient and
costly for you to actually go
in and out of bitcoin um and it really
kind of destroys your ability to
huddle long term if you want to but
um kind of going back to the original
question um
we think thoughtful regulation is the
best way to get as many people
into uh bitcoin crypto ethereum
defy um and so that's why we we
dedicated the last
now six years of our lives to to
um uh working on that and building
gemini
with that yeah i mean i was speaking to
raul powell about
um regulation and he was sort of saying
that if we want it to be if we want
bitcoin to be the next big thing if we
want it to be this store of value that
you know outperforms gold and so on
regulation is necessary for the big
names to get in like you know we saw
with microstrategy
um otherwise you know it just stays as
something that
people use within the community and it
is what it is um but i guess you know
we all sort of want it really to take
off you know we spin it against the gold
narrative and one day once
everybody's in right gemini
might look different um it could have
more of a decentralized
clearing mechanism that involves the
blockchain
or whatnot so um we're a living
breathing
organism a company like any good company
you're always looking to
disrupt yourself you know you're not
just placing on what's your current
stack look like
um or protecting your franchise business
you're looking out on the horizon like
what's the next frontier
and we may have different stacks right
now we're
a sex or a checks or whatever you want
to call it a centralized
exchange um and we could have you know
different
stacks for different customers depending
on where
the market evolves and speaking of
gemini developing you've obviously just
launched the earn feature so tell us
about this
and how does it compare to what blockfy
have what celsius network have
crypto.com
yeah so we um we just increased what we
call the money verbs at gemini
um so buy and sell are two
verbs right two actions you can take and
then store
um and now earn and so you can lend your
crypto and earn yield or
earn interest on that um i think our
rates are
are really competitive um but also
like our trust brand and the fact that
we're a new york trust company
everything we're doing is regulated
and so you sort of have that layer of
trust
over um the the the offering which
really doesn't
i think exist anywhere else um there are
other places offshore that are
unregulated
that um you know will offer yield
but uh buyer beware because there's no
recourse
um and things like that so we think i
mean that's that's like the
the number one question i tend to get is
people want to understand like what is
the safety and security here behind it
because
you you buy bitcoin or whatever you want
to hodl it you also want to protect that
value
and you want to make sure that you're
protecting it and it's safe in yield and
we think we've
built a really great product uh that
that helps consumers get yield but also
protects them and things like that
and i think we're the only people in new
york state for example big state
um that offers it in a regulated manner
so
uh we're really excited about it and
we're gonna be rolling it out to other
parts
of the world as well and adding more
assets to it uh
coming in the next couple weeks so where
is it available right now
uh i believe we're in all 50 u.s states
right now
uh so basically all of america um
looking at other international areas
um more assets and uh
and so it's it's sort of in a we're in
like a soft launch mode i think next
week it gets opened up to everyone
um the the numbers are pretty staggering
um in terms of like the uptake um i
won't disclose them
right this moment other than saying that
um
it it's been really phenomenal to watch
uh the other
thing that we got the the other recent
product launch that
this brings to mind is our credit card
offering
where you can basically swipe your
credit card and earn crypto
uh rewards back people uh are going
crazy for that
they're really excited because um
it's a behavior that we all do and
instead of getting
silly rewards points or airline miles
you can now actually invest and save
as you spend your your cash which is
quickly becoming trash because of all
the money spending
um and it turns consumers into into
investors
and that's that's a really cool uh
element and it's a great way to access
crypto
in an easy to understand manner because
one of the other questions that i often
get asked is like well when do i buy how
do i time it how much should i buy
and this takes those questions and
thought out of it
um where you just sort of can kind of do
it on an ongoing basis
yeah i think it's really exciting just
to sort of see how this space is moving
and i really like the idea that you know
you can earn you said you can earn
was it bitcoin back you said right you
can get your cash back in bitcoin
excuse me any um any crypto that we
support i think we have about okay
rick's right now um and so you could
choose bitcoin you could choose
ethereum you could choose uh litecoin
whatever token that we support i think
that's great because i
i use a lot of different cards um
because they all do different things
just slightly differently and
um i don't like to get my cash back in
their own token
um because it devalues unfortunately
really quickly um
but i guess
especially when you can't fly anyway
right right exactly you know
um yeah so if this pandemic continues
then at least we
get our bitcoin or ethereum back but
speaking of ethereum
you guys are super bullish on eth um
which is really cool to see
so i'd love to know why what is it um
because obviously you know bitcoin is
sort of the heart and soul of this but
it's quite cool to hear that you're into
eth so whoever wants to go for it
yeah we've been long-term eth hodlers um
pretty much since inception and we're
actually the first regulated exchange
in the world to list ether i think in
april of 2016.
so we've been big supporters of the
project for a long time
and if bitcoin is sort of the store of
value like think of it as digital gold
that's filling that quadrant
of money um or utility
um ethereum is really this like
decentralized operating system where you
can build
apps or smart contracts or really
whatever you want
and to run these apps or contracts you
need ether
so it's sort of like the digital oil of
this operating system
and it powers a lot of this stuff and so
as
more and more apps get sort of built on
top of ethereum
then there's greater demand for for
ether and so we're seeing an explosion
in decentralized finance right now where
people are building
lending applications and exchanges or
decentralized exchanges like
called dexes and people are uh you know
basically re-architecting financial
services on the ethereum blockchain
and um i think you know people are are
naturally
very bullish about the prospects because
when you think about the possibilities
of of uh operating system they're sort
of limitless
the kind of what you could build and we
we have no idea i mean a year from now
the things that are going to be coming
out um we're going to look back and say
wow i
can conceptualize that um it's this sort
of cambrian explosion
of of ideas and and and
development and so when we think of the
value of bitcoin and we actually wrote a
piece
on on uh the case for five hundred
thousand
dollar bitcoin we published it in august
um it's on our website
winklevosscapital.com
and we basically said look we think
bitcoin overtakes gold for these reasons
if you look at the market cap of gold
it's like an eight nine trillion dollar
uh market cap and so we backed into 500
000 a coin i think bitcoin was trading
at 13
000 in in august when we published
it's now at 37 000. um
it's it's making progress but it's still
like 15
times off of where we think it can be
within the next decade that's sort of
the time
within the deck the next day it's been a
decade it could be as fast as five years
um but we're very confident that within
the decade
um but ethereum is sort of if you take
the operating system of ios and
window and linux sort of
is all of that potential or cloud
computing it's all of that
potential and it's really hard to put a
ceiling or a framework
on creativity you know in
what that means um so how do you value
that
um well i can tell you that at fifteen
hundred dollar ether today it's sixteen
hundred dollars but yeah
the all-time high was breached i think
um a day or two ago
and that was reached three years ago and
the amount of work that's gone on
and the the development and maturity of
the network in the past three years
you're looking at ethereum basically at
its all-time high
um it feels like really undervalued uh
where it currently is um bitcoin is
twice what it's all time
or close to twice its all-time high of
three years ago so
we think there's a lot of value there
and um
loved sort of the endless possibilities
and nature
of it so i take it then you guys are
quite
for the whole d5 movement um because i
think although people are pro eth
sometimes a lot of people sort of think
defy is just
a shambles um what's your take
so we're definitely pro defy we've
listed uh dozens of d5 tokens on gemini
um we're really uh very supportive
it's early days right and and and uh
it's in the process of sort of building
the building blocks or the money legos
and putting them together
and re-architecting um uh
centralized finance um and there's risk
right it's not
the most user-friendly experience
there's there's definitely risk
some projects will will fail
spectacularly and some
some of them will be incredibly
successful um
and so it's new and and that has to be
sort of the lens at which you approach
it but
i think what's happening the the
foundational
start of it is is really um amazing
and and it doesn't compete with bitcoin
that's like one of the big things
and unfortunately um you you see is
people become maxies or maximalists and
they're like
only bitcoin or only ethereum or only
you know whatever token and it doesn't
have to be the case because they're
solving totally different things and
you know we we often talk about like if
you look at sport right the world's best
gymnast in the world
looks a lot different than the world's
best bodybuilder they're both phenomenal
at what they do
but a gymnast wouldn't be you know a
great bodybuilder
and and vice versa they'd be really
horrible at each other's sports
um and uh and so they're doing different
things and there's room for a couple of
amazing projects another really cool one
that we're bullish and investors in is
file coin it's creating this
decentralized
uh data storage layer so you think of
um storing your files on
on dropbox right well there's a
potential that dropbox says you know
some point hey
we don't really want to store your files
sorry we're closing you down
um uh and there's censorship resistant
uh risks um and and i think that um
they're also not built to like interact
with blockchain so if you're building a
decentralized app
on ethereum that needs to store data
um you know file coins a really
interesting
place to store encrypted data and the
token is is
the filecoin is the token or the asset
of that network
um that's a really cool project it's not
competing with bitcoin it's not helping
ethereum in fact it's creating synergies
and things like that so
we don't prescribe to the sort of the
maximalist philosophy we like
looking at projects are they solving
like unique problems
what are the teams behind this what's
like the the genesis the origin story
and then going from there um there's
probably not going to be hundreds and
hundreds
um but there's not going to be one or
two or three there's going to be
a number of really exciting crypto
projects
i i'd also say that um you know whether
or not
you believe in d fire works it actually
has a chance of solving the problems
that we saw last week
with robin hood right centralized
finance
the fact that all of the power is held
in
so few hands um d5 has got a shot
at completely re-architecting the
financial infrastructure and reimagining
and rebuilding wall street in a
decentralized permissionless
credibly neutral uh manner and i think
that's
that's a huge idea and there's
tremendous promise so
like i have to be our cheerleader of
that yeah
i'm totally with you um you know people
also sort of look at africa as a
sort of um a let's say an example of
where
this stuff could become really useful
where they don't have the financial
infrastructure that we have
in the west and they sort of skip um you
know entire revolutions um
i just think with d5 i think it just
needs more time it needs more
credibility
it needs more work and you know as we
always say think you know we're still
early
um but i'm with you i'm so excited to
see how it completely changes things it
takes the power back
yeah and also like um if you can't get a
loan right
from your board yeah exactly you can't
get a bank account can't get a loan you
can start a business you can't mortgage
your house
maybe use that to start a business like
so many people
the the decision of your financial
future whether you're not
able to prepare uh to create you know
create wealth your family
and build a better like situation for
yourself
um and your family is a decision made by
a few people at a bank
so that's what i love about the fact of
defy it's like you're interacting with a
smart contract if you
if you deposit um the the collateral or
whatever
you can you can borrow or you can lend
and smart contracts don't discriminate
for
any reason at all computer code is not
bias
that's not the case with humans that's
not the case with
all these gatekeepers so i think that's
really important a lot of people
um kind of miss that part too maybe
is how democratic and if you literally
have a smartphone
um you know in an internet connection
you can all of a sudden get access to
credit access
you can save um you know life savings
you have you have
basically a bank in in your pocket
and you have the basic tools to create a
better life
for yourself to grow your wealth
for yourself your family and your future
generations
um and that's just like too big to
overlook
so do you guys hold any d5 tokens any
coins like link
we're not on the link train uh actually
we've done it
a de minimis amount but not um not large
large but uh it's it's a very
interesting project we we support it on
gemini
uh the link marines are a very
passionate group
um it's always fun interacting with them
on twitter yeah for sure so just quickly
back to bitcoin for a sec you know you
mentioned you think it could surpass
gold so what is your general view for
bitcoin and the space
do you see it as um you know the reserve
currency do you see it as
a day-to-day payment solution or just as
a store of value
um i think store value definitely
emergent
you know obviously it's got its work cut
out for it it's still
um you know needs to be a multi-trillion
dollar
uh uh asset to to sort of really have
arrived in that direction
um we're seeing companies put it on
their balance sheet
attacked against inflation with all the
money printing that's happened in covid
um and even really before then um and we
think that there will be some central
banks and governments that like actually
start buying bitcoin and putting it on
their balance sheet and understand
the value they they've uh you know been
using gold and buying gold for
for many many many years um we think
bitcoin
is just around the corner there um so
really exciting and then does it become
sort of this reserve currency of the
internet very
very possibly um that it's kind of where
people store their value and then then
they move in and out of bitcoin and
other things when they need to build
smart contracts on ethereum or whatever
and then move that value
back into something like you know
bitcoin so
um we think it's super interesting and
it cannibalizes the the
gold uh that story gets even more
interesting when you look
at um how much gold there is in the
universe we wrote about this this summer
and um i think people thought we were a
little crazy
that's true but there's there's billions
if not trillions of uh
dollars of gold emotional sitting on
asteroids floating around this planet um
i think elon musk and nassau they've
already got a mission
um to explore uh a particular asteroid i
forget what the name of the mission is
psyche okay so that's that ship has
already left literally physically
yeah it's much right and so this idea of
putting a probe on an asteroid and
starting to potentially
investigate what's actually in it and
potentially
mine it um it's not sci-fi it's it's not
out there it's it's it's truly it's
probably within the next 25 years
and this idea that gold is scarce it's
really just because the technology
hasn't been there it's been like an
access to space problem we've barely
sort of scratched the earth
look at oil uh the us is now a net
exporter of oil
um not thought possible 15 years ago
and then fracking technology came about
and we're now pulling out tons of oil
and um we're literally selling it to
other countries
so uh yeah we think the gold story is
not
good long term um and and that sort of
further
highlights the need for for bitcoin
which is a truly fixed asset the only
asset of its kind in the observable
universe more demand cannot will not
uh increase supply and that's that's an
amazing thing
yeah i think uh i think i made a video
um maybe a few a few months ago about
there being gold on asteroids and i
definitely got the same response like
people thought i was absolutely nuts
that's just insane yeah one thing is i
recently read
an investor letter from a
very uh blue chip wall street fiduciary
firm
um that is in um uh in bitcoin
um and they talked about uh bitcoin or
gold mining on asteroids so it's
happening you're just an early adopter
like us it's like
it's classic right when we got into
bitcoin and started talking about it
people ridicule laugh you know make fun
of and now all of a sudden
you become you're the smartest person in
the room and it's the same thing
with um mining gold on on asteroids it's
like that
famous quote i don't know it's uh
ascribe to gandhi
first they ignore ignore you then they
laugh at you then they fight you then
you win
it's the same thing for every
entrepreneur um
or or actually frankly a good investor
is that you sort of look crazy
um and people sort of ridicule you but
then all of a sudden your thesis
proves right and you know you are the
smartest person
you you you can't have consensus when
you're talking about the future
or the frontier or something innovative
or forward thinking you have to be
alone and be willing to be alone on your
thinking there
um and so that's just part of like when
people
disagree or sort of have that reaction i
kind of feel like i know i'm onto
something
yeah i want to just like quickly delve
into this a little bit um
because like i said you guys were at the
forefront of the two biggest revolutions
some people might have said before you
guys stumbled onto bitcoin that the
first one was just circumstantial having
been at harvard and so on
um but but it's obviously not and you
guys are doing incredible stuff
um what would you say i guess
is the key to it's a hard question i
appreciate that so
what did you say the key is to sort of
entrepreneurship and
um you know really going for something
and spotting that
that needle in a haystack i guess or the
diamond in a rough
yeah i mean i think that that it's a
it's a great question and i think
that um creativity is so important and i
think a lot of people get sort of pushed
off their authentic selves
and they kind of lose that that spark
and and they sort of get pushed off of
of what they
really think is cool and they go end up
like
sort of going down paths that are pretty
straightforward and in the box so i
think
like um really sort of staying true to
your own creativity is really the only
way to be competitive
and build in that infinite game um
where there's just unknowns um i mean
when we started gemini
bitcoin was really like the only like
thing out there
um we didn't we couldn't have predicted
a lot of what's happened and yet we knew
if we built like a
a cool t a great team brilliant people
we're just gonna find
cool things to do here and so that's
part of it um
it's incredibly sort of uh stressful and
hard work
and very narrow um like you you have to
give up things you will give up a ton
to do it and and like what have you guys
given up
um just uh a lot of like
time time yeah like your own personal
time right
you know sometimes you're you're pulling
just uh you're working
non-stop through weekends for months
but but it doesn't feel like you're
working that's the key
right that's why um it's a good idea for
us to be entrepreneurs but if
it feels like a sacrifice too much or
too much time
um then it's probably not the right
adventure for you
because it is literally one of the
hardest things
you can do and take on your life we
trained for
15 years to become olympic athletes
and that was a very difficult difficult
pursuit
um starting a company is in the same
realm
there are differences um but you give up
a lot of
or you know ostensibly give up a lot of
things
but it doesn't feel like that to us and
that's the key is it doesn't feel like
we're working
but if we punched our hours we're never
not working you know we never
it's it's not a nine to five you check
in check out
um always on twitter always on slack
always doing things
whether it's eleven o'clock at night one
o'clock at night
six in the morning depending on the day
people ask like are you
do you get a you know do you wake up
early well it depends on the morning
depends on what the mission
calls for sometimes i'm up at 4 00 4 30
in the morning five in the morning and
some mornings
i'm up at eight or nine um some nights
i'm in bed at 9 30
just totally exhausted some some you
know for whatever reason
you're up till one or even later so
it's literally you have to be able to to
to take that
on and adjust and and smile
while you're doing it and love it and
realize that you'd be miserable
doing anything else you'd be miserable
working for the man you'd be miserable
trying to become partner at the
investment bank
or the law firm and some people love
that they love that certainty they're
like i want that linear path from where
i am right now
to where i'm going to be in 20 years
that is
comforting to me i don't want to swim
with the risk of other people's money
and employing a lot of people um and
building a company um i love that risk
it doesn't feel like risks i sleep very
well at night
um even though you know other people
might look at me and like you're you're
carrying the weight of the world and
juggling all this stuff so
you got to find what's the right
adventure for you i mean for us
it's building a company yeah i mean i
can i can actually totally relate
because i i used to work mad hours
as a journalist for china's global tv
network and i'm talking like
six in the morning until midnight no
weekends so that
that obviously builds up and i hated it
and i was absolutely miserable
um whereas now sometimes i'm working
even more
definitely working on the weekends given
we're unlocked down here in the uk
and it's fun it doesn't feel like work
because you know you're building your
own dream
um so it makes sense and i think i think
i saw um
somebody tweet something like
entrepreneurs are the only people that
would sort of leave a
a job just to work more hours that's a
good um
um but it's really it's it's i think
work is is that
one of those funny words that like
implies like
an arduous task and and i think when
you're doing what you love
it tends to be more play and you're in
flow and and it it doesn't feel like
work and i think that's kind of the key
here um and and just finding like that
that passion in that area where it
doesn't feel like work
and you're willing to put in as much
time
as it takes and probably you know tons
more than if you're just working at a
normal job
so and i think also figuring out like
what what drives you like
what is what is your purpose your
mission your why
um and that's a tough thing and it
sometimes takes people a long time to
figure that out
if they ever do um some people like
love to sort of give back um they need
to be in the peace corps and do that
kind of
uh service you know others want to build
or create um so i think finding
that is is is actually really important
and we often um
i find it sort of later on um
well after we started creating a company
and then we're like okay now i get it
now i know why
you're how i got here but you sort of
felt it instinctually
but you didn't actually like write it
down on a piece of paper yeah
and the other thing i'd say is it's not
just about hard work right
because um elon musk doesn't have
more hours in the day than than uri it's
it's also about like obviously there's
going to be hard work
but we don't want to celebrate that in
in itself right
um it's about building great teams it's
about creating
leverage through great teams it's about
delegating decentralizing
decision making building a culture of
innovation so you're just not coming up
with only ideas
it's leveraging through scale through
code through technology through all
these things
that allow the same people with the same
amount of
hours in their day to have a
dramatically different input
on the other side um so it is hard work
it's it's going to be a challenge
but also it's not just as simple as like
it's not the pursuit isn't
banging your head against the wall right
it's it's working smart
working with leverage um to build
something really great that's what
really
separates um a good company from a great
company
yeah i think smart work is an important
one hard work means nothing
without smart work but just a personal
question for both of you
um so what's it like kind of going
through this
jungle of life and sort of having each
other right so
from college from dealing with facebook
you know business together
you know passing in ibiza together to
building all these things together
what's it like to literally have each
other you know because you're not
tackling this on your own
which i think is insane really cool yeah
it's awesome i mean you have like a
co-founder
like built in and we we so i'm
left-handed tyler's right-handed so we
do actually
yeah that's amazing mirror image twins
and uh we we have different styles
um but we have obviously like a shared
set of values
um and so we're not sitting around
ratifying each other all day long we're
actually challenging each other
and being thought partners um and
calling
or or offering like constructive
feedback
um it's gotten more constructive as we
get older you know but sometimes when
you're younger years like ah
you know um but the point being is is
we're we're teammates
and we've been teammates for a long time
whether it's in the rowing arena
athletics um in litigation
founding a company um and it's really
exciting because we sort of have
different points of views
um and and so i think it's worked really
well we're not sort of the same person
that would be really boring and we'd
probably make bad decisions because
we'd both be kind of uh you know self
ratifying each other
and things like that and i think there's
we've created that space where we can
have really healthy
disagreement and and build you know um
strategy around that so um it's been
it's been really
really great
what are your thoughts tyler how's it
been having cameroon with you this whole
time
i thought that was the point of having a
twin brother you can just answer no
never yeah so to bring it to crypto like
um in terms of values like
foundationally on unlike layer one
we're the same right but as you go up
the stack
we have different preferences um but
what's key
the number one thing you gotta pick is
value alignment you know
what like your ideas of integrity
character
honesty truth those things you've got to
get right with your
your partners your employees um
the next sort of layers like abilities
um horsepower raw horsepower like
values abilities are hard to change and
they're kind of fully baked
by the time you're an adult
skills are the easy things to change or
learn
like we can take some with good values
great abilities at gemini
and almost no skills and give them the
skills teach them the skills and in fact
it's sometimes better
because experience is just another word
for like bad assumptions
or um like poor skills or skills we want
to like d
train because um this is crypto it's a
frontier everything's different
new so you got to get the values
alignment and then you want that
respectful discourse you want that
disagreement because
that's how great ideas are made is the
sort of like
respectfully butting heads it's not
consensus
of a committee um so we very much
um followed that in our relationship i
might you know turn on a song or
something and
like oh that's a good song and cameron's
like i don't really like that like
that's great
you know that's yeah we can argue like
why do you think that this way
um well i think this is the problem with
the guitar line or
you know the the lyrics or the sound or
the tone or whatever the pitch
um so we can kind of go back and forth
and that's just like it's intellectual
sparring you know we're like
uh intellectual jogging partners you
want to surround yourself by those
people
where you have that space um and grace
to
challenge each other and always hire
people smarter than you
that's rule number one a lot of people
like it's crazy but on ego they want to
be like
key person narcissistic system you just
want to like have a
pluses around you and you want like
people are more successful
smarter better looking whatever um
because it just levels you up
yeah absolutely what do they say you are
the sum of the five people we spend the
most time with
um but guys just finally what are you
doing next what's the vision for gemini
what can we expect i would say one of
the
the coolest uh things that we're really
excited about
is nft non-fungible tokens arden
collectibles so we actually bought a
platform
uh niftygateway.com which is now a
gemini
gemini family and um we relaunched a
platform i think in march
of of 2020 and it's really been growing
like a weed and really exciting there's
um some amazing artists and content on
it
and these are you know these are pieces
of art that are verifiable
and they live on the blockchain and we
think that's really the next frontier of
like art and collectibles
and um people are getting really excited
i mean the energy
again reminds us of like early bitcoin
like well what is this thing and and
it's still like hard for a lot of people
to get like
what do you mean like digital art can't
i just take a screen grab of it
like how you know what is this canvas
and this medium
and and the the the simple answer is you
can go to the louvre
and take a photo of the mona lisa with
your iphone doesn't mean you
own the mona lisa or whatever and uh
it's it's we think it's a really
exciting frontier and you're going to
hear more and more of it
uh we've had drops from artists and and
recording artists and all kinds of
things so it's it's been cool
nice all right well yeah go on and say
tyler yeah and i
to say um i'm reading through the
comments um oh i haven't read them yet
oh no
uh it's very colorful um a lot of
interactions
um but um should we take like a rapper
and
fire uh a couple let's definitely do
that
let's definitely do it let me have a
look through guys if you have any
questions you want to ask then
put them in now because there are like
hundreds of questions
right it would be easier if uh people
just even if they had put a question up
up top just put it in right now so we
can see it and not have to scroll
all right let's have a look they're
coming through so can we ask layer a
question no ask them a question come on
guys
they're coming through would you like
okay
let's oh gosh here we go hang on
let me get that back will you offer a
debit card uh yes looking into it
okay that's great oh this is going so
fast bear with me
with me uh on lake huron uh yeah
maybe that sounds kind of fun old sailor
traitor
here we go thoughts on ada cardano
um haven't looked at it close enough yep
okay um let's get some more they're
moving really quite
fast it's hard to get them up let's have
a look we've already answered that one
here we go when do you plan on adding
more projects to gemini
uh soon we're actually looking at more
token listings
right now okay let's have a look there's
more here
were you branch to sport nfts
yes and i think we've actually already
done athlete and brand ft's
so that's actually already happened but
definitely i mean
when i think of like nfts i think of
digital art and collectibles
so everything that's happening in the
trading cars market like the offline
meet space like the psa 10
jordan rookies and stuff we're looking
at bringing that
on to the blockchain so definitely do
more sports stuff
and collabs with artists and athletes
for sure will you ever retire
no because we're not working i retired
when i started gemiini
not um no i think what would we do with
ourselves
um it's so exciting that's like saying
will i ever get off twitter
i mean all my friends all those my
internet friends i won't i won't have
them anymore
um that's that's hard hard to imagine
that future
what's tyler and cameron's favorite book
so i'll tell you two books that are i
think are incredible for any
entrepreneur
recently read no rules rules it's the
netflix book
i read hastings and i think erica meyer
but you can google that if i got that
wrong
um so good talks about their culture all
the
the insights um i really liked it i
found myself
nodding a lot like hey this makes a lot
of sense thank you for putting words
uh to that and uh also um
every every entrepreneur should read
zero to one by peter thiel
sort of the art of a startup it's a
short little book
there's so many pearls of wisdom in
there building a company and startups
even angel investing
is very counterintuitive and uh peter
lays this out perfectly so uh i would
definitely those are must reads for sure
working as influential entrepreneurs
what is your view on this modern pc work
culture that's a cool one
modern pc work culture i guess you need
everybody we use personal computers
every day
all right let's see what else we've got
here have you considered integrating
with trainingview.com
for gemini that'd be cool that's
interesting question because we actually
have
um and i think we've had an integration
with tradingview for
almost a year so you can link your
tradingview account with
gemini and trade all the cryptos that we
offer
what are your thoughts on privacy i
guess they mean privacy coins
um we list c cash um and we
we turned on shielded addresses i think
uh this fall
and we believe there's like a real need
for for privacy
uh commercial privacy in in finance um
and transactions and so and i think we
were the first
like regulated exchange in the world to
list c cash and maybe still the only one
um the way we did that is we really
engaged with regulators
and and work with them to sort of
demystify a lot of this um
after all regulators are are comfortable
with cash right and and so
z cash is is very much uh takes sort of
the properties of
of uh analog real world meet space cache
to the blockchain and uh a lot of
education but we got it done
and we got them comfortable and we're
really excited to support the project
and we think it's a really
really good one this is a great question
does spirituality play any role in your
lives and business making decisions
um like horoscopes or something no i
guess well i'm gonna guess they mean
more
is a horoscope you know there's some
spirituality there um
i think yeah look i think um
when you think of like spirituality and
like following the charm of the universe
and like
letting nature sort of author like a
path so to speak
um that's like very much uh
in line with with entrepreneurship and
building a company right you you cannot
be
rigid um and you cannot cling to things
that are no longer relevant
um a lot of times you know we go down
paths and we say oh wait a second that's
no longer makes sense or whatever and
you you pull back
and you follow sort of um that
serendipity in many ways that's how we
found bitcoin
serendipity we were we were just sort of
open and we have this value at gemini
called beginner's mind where
we approach things with the mind of a
beginner we don't bring assumptions
from um you know past experience that
can
cloud our decision making because a lot
of people saw bitcoin
but they didn't invest they did the
opposite they they either
went the other way or they they
ridiculed it um
and a lot of those folks have come
around uh since then
but that is a really important value
um in how we think about it and is very
much i think
uh in like the spirituality
domain i think it's a concept that you
find in in
uh meditation and and uh
um self-improvement a lot um
and so we think i think i think very
much spirituality is part of
what you're doing you have like this
higher calling this mission
otherwise just go work for the man go go
do you know
another job right i think joel loved
your answer he says thank you
um and what about doge when is that
available
can't disclose um but but it's uh it's a
really interesting
vote with the um the audience uh just if
you want to see doge on gemini put a
plus one
oh that'll be cool and if you think we
shouldn't
put a minus they still put a plus one
with all your success
what do you consider as your greatest
achievement
gosh um i think the the
the group of people we've assembled at
gemini
um flattered and honored that these
folks
took a risk on us took a leap of faith
on us
and ultimately trust us to lead them
to the moon so that is definitely
one of my top uh if not the
uh top maybe even personal
accomplishments or it's definitely
let's put in the professional bucket
yeah i i have to echo that one um you
know it's such a privilege and honor to
work with our team
um and a lot of them you know they've
taken a risk on
our vision and and both crypto but also
our vision
and leadership and uh it's it's really
kind of such a pleasure to to work with
with uh
our team and i think that was super
amazing um
also rowing in the olympics was was
definitely a super amazing highlight to
to represent our country and and really
be part of
uh the olympic movement which is which
is really much more than
than just uh sport you know it's it's
it's really a
a piece a piece movement um and that was
that was a really exciting journey
um so i'd say those two are are high up
there
bit of a cheeky question are you guys um
in touch with anybody
from facebook so we're in contact with
dustin
uh moscowitz we actually ran into him we
went to burning man in 2013 and 2014.
and i i can't i think it was 2013 we
actually
uh randomly serendipitously met
um and sort of kept in touch um so i
think he's the only
guy we we are in touch with
from facebook i have a feeling that if
we ran into severan
we would be friends um you know given
that we went through sort of similar
things a little bit
yeah but i don't know if we've met
any of the other um founding team
actually other than mark of course
have you guys ever tried out nano what
do you think of it
i haven't tried it out i don't think how
about you karen
a nano nano it's a crypto it's quite an
interesting one
no i'll have to check it out all right
there there they've got a great
community um they're gonna be
they're really happy that you uh that
you talked about that um any thoughts on
bitcoin cash
i think so bitcoin cash is a fork of
of um bitcoin uh came about through a
disagreement
in uh transaction speed and throughput
um look i think i think it's great that
other you know if other people want to
build other
communities and projects that's awesome
i think it's healthier to sort of
not have a lot of disagreement you know
just fork it and go your own way
um haven't stayed that close to the
project but i think um
you know look it's it's a project out
there we support it on gemini for
listing and trading so
um if you if you want to buy some you
know
we offer it will gemini have their own
token like binance
um not anytime soon we have
well we have a stable coin so we have i
don't know the binance token but if
it um but we have a stable coin called
the gemini dollar it's a one to one peg
with the dollar i'm also looking at a
a question that says flexa how easy is
the relationship in
flexor team is fantastic they
they feel like the gemini team there's
so much value alignment they literally
fit in
um like a glove in gemini and we've had
an incredible
relationship with them and we look
forward to um
doing some great stuff uh continued
stuff in the future
for sure all right um i think
just the last one last question gemini
earn live
um meaning like is it live the the
product i think that's what they're
asking
yeah so we we offer uh it's open to a
select group of customers
as we sort of test and roll it out um we
just want to make sure everything's you
know
it's a new new product but it it should
be open for everyone
within a week or so and we'll message on
twitter follow you know
gemiini on twitter um or our blog or or
myself at cameron or at tyler
if you want to uh stay up to date but
it'll be out very very soon
um and uh thanks for asking
gemini is also available in portugal
uh someone just asked and also
netherlands um
and pretty much i think everywhere in in
the european
uh economic area or europe so check it
out
all right guys thank you so much for
coming on um and i'm sure the audience
is super pleased um about the ama
great idea um thank you so much for
coming on it's been so interesting to
learn
more about you and understand you know
what's coming up with gemiini next
thanks for having us this was a lot of
fun yeah thanks for having us thank you
audience for being
lively and having the great questions
and we look forward to coming on again
in the future
not too long from now absolutely speak
soon bye
all right see ya
[Music]
[Applause]